[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que tu veux faire quand tu
seras plus grands qui n'a pas déjà
entendu cette question enfant je pouvais
pas la supporter car je n'arrivais pas à
choisir un seul métier je voulais être
cuisinier inventeur kinésithérapeute
biologiste et explorateur aujourd'hui je
suis designer indépendant
le design permet de réunir de canaliser
tous les autres métiers
je découvre j'apprends j'expérimente
continuellement de nouveaux domaines et
je m'en inspire pour créer des objets
utiles durable et métissé par le voyage
bon j'ai mis du temps à trouver cette
voie au début j'ai simplement suivi le
mouvement avec une première année de
médecine
pourquoi paquin est mal orienté je me
rends compte
le deuxième jour que l'université où
j'ai atterri ne prépare pas kiné trois
mois plus tard j'ai 19 ans je lâche tout
je prends mon sac à dos pour l'autre
bout du monde
l'inde cette étape me fait prendre du
recul j'ai cultive ma curiosité
ma sensibilité qui me portent jusqu'à
l'école boulle en section design
là je suis tout de suite séduit par la
puissance créatrice de l'école
en fait cette émulation me renforce dans
l'idée que l'art appliqué peut modeler
le monde petit à petit projet à projet
et durant ces trois ans je découvre la
richesse des métiers d'art de france
alors quelle différence fer entre
artisans et designers
bien sûr ce ne sont que des étiquettes
certains créatifs sont les deux à la
fois je ferai quand même cette
distinction
l'artisan vient transformer un produit
par un savoir faire
il est plus souvent experts d'un domaine
d'un matériau on pourrait le comparer à
son outil favori comme un ciseau à bois
pour un ébéniste donc un outil affûté à
un travail particulier le designer lui
est davantage un créatif
pluridisciplinaire dont le but serait
d'adoucir la vie
il s'oriente s'inspire de tout des
milieux sociaux scientifiques
environnementaux et même politique
donc le designer est plus un couteau
suisse multifonctions mais peu
spécialisés voyager c'est aller de soi
vers soi en passant par les autres ce
proverbe touareg m'inspire chaque jour
et me pousse à repartir en voyage
après mon diplôme un voyage où je vais
prendre le temps où je vais laisser
place à l'imprévu
un voyage où je vais m'imprégner de mes
découvertes de mes rencontres
un voyage pour m'inscrire dans un
territoire qu'il soit proche ou lointain
en fait vous savez ce qui est fascinant
quand on voyage quand on est l'étranger
c'est qu'on transporte avec nous un
autre regard un regard qui se pose sur
des différences des habitudes des
détails devenu invisible pour les locaux
et c'est cette étrangeté qui va agir
comme un terreau d'imaginaire et qui va
permettre aux idées de germer
spontanément je pars donc six mois à
taiwan dans l'institut national
d'artisanat le ntc m
cette résidence va me permettre d'allier
découverte artisanale à un environnement
9 et exaltant comme vous le savez
sûrement dans cette partie de l'asie la
médecine traditionnelle considère le
corps l'esprit commun tous traversé par
une même énergie le tchi cette
philosophie m'inspire un objet qui
améliore le sommeil en nous connectant
justement à notre propre flux
énergétiques knicks il est basé sur une
nouvelle méthode de repos validé par
l'inserm qui respecte nos cycles
biologiques alors comme vous pouvez le
voir ni que ces composés d'un cadran
d'inserts clémente et à l'intérieur et
de deux billes la première argentées
comme la nuit représente le coucher
la seconde cuivre et comme le jour
matérialise le lever dans un premier
temps pendant deux semaines
je note mes heures de réveil spontanée
de coups de fatigue je retiens l'heure
la plus récurrente qui indiquent un
début de cycle de sommeil pour moi c'est
18h30
j'ai toujours un coup de barre je règle
donc le cercle interne sur 18h30 knicks
repère alors mais cycles de sommeil en
rentrant chez moi en fin de journée je
projette simplement ma soirée et je pose
les billes aux horaires souhaités de
début et de fin de nuit
bon je vais dîner regarder un petit film
lire quelques pages disons 11h30 je dois
me lever assez tôt demain matin à les
six heures par aimantation chaque bille
se décale sur le début de cycle le plus
proche au coucher janser mon téléphone
d'enix et le réveil automatiquement
programmer à l'heure indiquée par
l'habit cuivre est en fait comme ça au
fil des semaines de nuit s'optimise avec
davantage de sommeil profond
récupérateur au point 4 heures 30 de
sommeil biologique vont être plus
régénératrice que huit heures de repos
classique ce qui était passionnant pour
ce projet c'est que j'ai été amené à
travailler avec des chercheurs des
ingénieurs des artisans d'ailleurs grâce
à knicks je découvre l'artisanat du bois
puisque je le prototype avec l'aide d'un
maître ébéniste makoto sung en fait ce
sont ces dialogue interprofessionnel qui
nourrissent mon énergie créative dans
cette dynamique je collabore à taïwan
avec une autre designer française
cordelia fort et ici au centre de la
photo à côté de moi nous expérimentons
ensemble de nombreux savoir-faire
traditionnels aux côtés de maître
artisan lac végétal bambou céramique
fibre est teintures naturelles la
culture taïwanaise nous inspire
énormément nous focalisons notre
attention sur des matières locales
invisible délaissés ou considérés comme
des déchets nous créons des objets
métissé la lampe d'ambiance nuque les
enchères de bananier amorce cette
nouvelle approche créative pour nous
elle redonne du sens au design en
intégrant l'histoire et la culture d'un
pays dans l'objet final
près de ou alien sur la côte est de
taïwan nous rencontrons la tribu
aborigène cavale and experte dans la
fibre de bananier ils en font leurs
vêtements traditionnels
pendant une semaine nous apprenons aux
côtés de leurs anciens la méthode
ancestrale du travail de cette plante
il extrait de la tige qui est plus de la
taille d'un tronc d'ailleurs une fibre
de quelques millimètres d'épaisseur
tout le reste toute la chair est laissée
de côté n'est pas valorisé nous nous
intéressons donc à cette chère que nous
expérimentons de manière empirique
réaction au chaud au froid à l'humidité
à la pression combinaison avec d'autres
matériaux la lumière révèlent un
graphisme fascinant au bout de plusieurs
semaines nous réussissons à stabiliser
ce tissu végétal en une gamme colorée
allant du blanc au brun foncé
puis nous inspirons de la structure du
bananier pour mettre en valeur ce
nouveau matériau dans des formes de
bambou cintrée deux autres projets nous
viennent à l'esprit
dans le village de look ang sur un petit
marché une vieille dame vendée lufa à
même le sol
par curiosité nous lui en achetons
quelques unes bon heureusement que j'ai
dit quelques unes
cette matière fibreuse provient de
l'intérieur de certaines courge très
courantes en asie à taïwan chaque grand
mère en a dans son petit potager fait
elle s'en sert d'éponger exfoliante sont
cueillies puis séchés au soleil jusqu'à
ce qu'il ne reste plus que le réseau de
fibre nous apprenons qu'il nous fasse
reproduisent rapidement avec un faible
impact écologique
nous essayons d'explorer ses propriétés
pour lui donner de nouveaux usages par
simple pressage on obtient un textile
fin qui reprend son volume originel
quand on le plonge dans l'eau découvrant
aussi des propriétés d'isolation
thermique d'absorption des chocs
nous imaginons shanghua des écrins 100%
biodégradables pour sertir et
transporter les bouteilles en toute
sécurité
la faculté qu'ont ces fibres à
s'entremêler entre elles sous la
pression mécanique nous conduit à un
autre projet luu quang en fait empressa
ensemble de nombreuses ou pas
obtenant une trame de longueur
d'épaisseur infinie sans aucun ajout
bon je sais les designers font une
fixette sur l'echez c'est un peu l'objet
incontournable pour moi c'est la
première ça va encore la partie en lufa
est réversible est garanti à vie comme
tout chaise l'assise peut être
endommagée au bout de plusieurs années
suffit de la retirer et de l'envoyer à
la fabrique le textile est plongé dans
l'eau les différentes ou fin se séparent
puis elles sont reprises et ensemble en
ajoutant des fibres à l'endroit déchiré
zéro déchet comme vous l'avez compris
c'est six mois ont été une révélation
toute une gamme d'objets emprunt de
notre compréhension de taiwan a vu le
jour à notre retour en france
nous voulons partager cette approche
alors avec nos anciens professeurs nous
organisons dans cet institut de taïwan
un workshop qui associe étudiants
designers de l'école boulle et artisans
taïwanais
ensemble ils imaginent de nouvelles
applications à de ressources locales
délaissé la noix de bétel et le papier
de mûrier aujourd'hui je continue à
suivre ce fil conducteur tressé
d'humains et de nature en fait ce qui me
fait vibrer c'est de travailler avec des
entreprises conscientes des enjeux
écologiques et sociaux pour lesquels
l'environnement est une philosophie plus
qu'une question d'image pour demain j'ai
un rêve déployer ma démarche par un
cheminement éco responsable de par le
monde rencontrer les acteurs de la
création des territoires que je traverse
valoriser leur savoir faire développé
avec eux des produits responsables
apportant des bribes de solutions aux
problématiques locales finalement
au delà de l'utile ma mission de
designers ne serait-elle pas de
témoigner de notre formidable diversité
culturelle quoi de plus inspirant que de
créer des objets métissé sensibles et
censés pour enchanter faire rêver nous
rapprocher d'autres cultures et ouvrir
nos horizons
merci
[Applaudissements]